LAURA LING: Rhinoceros are some
of the most endangered species
in the world.
They're poached for their horns,
which have been used primarily
in Asian countries as a
traditional medicine and status
symbol.
Demand for rhino horns
has been growing.
Last year, over
1,200 rhinos were
poached, which is roughly
one every eight hours.
It's believed the entire
rhino species could be
extinct within 5 to 10 years.
George Bonaci and
Matthew Markus,
co-founders of Pembient,
believe they can save the rhino
with their 3D printed horns.
This is a 3D printed
rhinoceros horn
that would be virtually
identical to a real rhino horn.
GEORGE BONACI: Exactly.
Their horns go for
$60,000 a kilogram.
LAURA LING: So this is more
expensive than cocaine?
GEORGE BONACI: Exactly, yes.
LAURA LING: So how do you
3D print a rhino horn?
GEORGE BONACI: So our
goal was to first start
with a powder that was
identical to the real thing.
We combined inorganics,
metals, minerals, as well as
other proteins.
We also incorporated real
rhino DNA into it, as well.
And then from there we were
thinking, how can we get this
into chunks, and then eventually
bigger and bigger shapes,
that will resemble
a real rhino horn?
And we ended up designing
our own 3D printer.
Using our powders really
build up an actual horn.
LAURA LING: So are you
saying that your 3D printed
horn is virtually the same as
a real born in shape, size,
structure?
GEORGE BONACI: Yes, yes.
We took it to a lab
and had them test it,
and it would come
back as rhino horn.
We did a DNA test.
It would come back
as from a rhino.
So we start it
off with a powder.
And this is how it's
typically consumed.
They'll grind the horn
down and consume it.
This was our first
3D printed prototype
that resembles a highly
oxidized rhino horn.
And then this is a
more recent prototype,
where we're trying to get
bigger and bigger, ultimately
to the full size, like 2
and 1/2 foot rhino horns.
LAURA LING: And how
do you guys plan
to get this onto the market?
GEORGE BONACI: So we're planning
on going through partnerships
with existing companies.
The supplement companies,
cosmetics companies.
A lot of the poachers in Africa
that are doing the killing,
they're doing it because
they're very poor.
And killing one rhino would
feed your family for years,
potentially.
So one idea we've had
would be giving it to them,
or selling it to them
at a large discount,
so they can then sell it through
the black market channels.
They still make a
living for their family.
The end user still gets it.
It's pure, but the
rhinos get to survive.
LAURA LING: There are
those critics out there
who had said that
this might actually
do more harm than good.
It's a noble idea,
but it might actually
legitimize this idea that
it is actual medicine,
or increase demand for it.
GEORGE BONACI: If
we can basically
fill the supply with an
identical product at a cheaper
price, it's going to decrease
the price for the product.
And therefore, there's going
to be less incentive to poach.
Why would you risk your
life and go and kill a rhino
and make a species
extinct, when you
can go buy it from a my
store for 1/10 the price?
Just going over to
Vietnam and telling people
to stop doing it, that
alone is not going to help.
You also need an alternative.
It'd be like if someone came
to the United States and said,
cutting down Christmas trees
at Christmas time is stupid,
there's no purpose.
Rhino horn is really just
a traditional thing you do.
LAURA LING: It's
pretty incredible
that this technology can
allow you to do this.
GEORGE BONACI: This probably
would not have been possible
5,10 years ago.
LAURA LING: How much
of a game changer
do you think this will be?
GEORGE BONACI: Well,
I hope and I believe
that it will save the species.
That's the reason
why we're doing it.
I think now is probably the
time to give it a try no matter
what.
And really, it might
be their only hope.
NARRATOR: Be sure to watch
this next episode of "Seeker
Stories."
LAURA LING: There
are some people
who say that what
you're suffering from
is not a condition.
It's an affliction,
it's in your head.
How does that make you feel?